so starting jumping right on in
I actually am going to embarrass someone
in a second you previously did Deadpool
and I'm now and actually we it's great
to see you come fook any completely it's
been a minute ladies and gentlemen kung
fu Kenny sing Gabe it's one of the
greatest love stories well I was
actually gonna say I want to embarrass
someone just for the eff of it where is
Rob Rob Liefeld right there no sir Rob
greater of Deadpool [ __ ] you can always
count on a reserve like thoughtful
reaction from everybody he's known for
anyway yeah I am curious can I get a hug
fuckin'-a what's up by the way these
credits will still be rolling by the
time we're done with this that's how
many people working on this movie yeah I
thought I would definitely have time to
go to the bathroom but you guys started
early who wins in a fight between the
t800 and Deadpool I know I know I know I
have a new love but it you clearly can
kill just make more and exactly okay do
you ever thought on this between your
model of the Terminator and I mean I'm
kind of partial to the big man you know
I got a I got a sit in his corner and
cheer him on and when one goes down I
just throw another one in there and I'll
just make another one and I just keep
making them so I don't know I got a but
yeah that's a good that's a good
question it's good match it they should
add him to Mortal Kombat so we can find
out what was it so you finished after
Deadpool what was it about terminator
that said I want to do this next and
show actually David Ellison who runs
skydance who controls the rights to
terminator David actually came to a
rough cut of Deadpool because he was
talking about another project with me
and then we bonded in this nerd like
moment of sci-fi love of film and and
terminator and he said you know I [ __ ]
it up first time and I want another
chance and would you be interested in
helping Jim Cameron wasn't attached
again at that time and one of the things
I said was well we got to get Jim to
come back and like give it the nerd
stamp of approval because otherwise you
know how are they going to know it's not
gonna suck so you guys you work it out
that you're gonna do it I know you guys
had this writers room that well you
broke down story with a number of people
Cameron was there can you talk about
that writers room who was in it and what
you guys were what you came up with and
you know in those weeks you were in
there yeah we had a few writers rooms
and we had a novelist room and remember
that originally we were were breaking
story for three films not because we
were arrogant and assumed
of course everyone will pay for three
movies it's really just you you want to
have a complete story with a complete
park and you do this first movie and you
hope that maybe there's another chance
but I hate you know movies that like
deliberately seed the next movies and I
feel like you're advertising you know
movie - and the movie that I paid for so
I tried very hard to feel like a
complete story but anyway we did this
writers room with novelists because I
love science fiction and we had we had
Neil Stevenson and Greg bear and my
favorite author of all time Joe
Abercrombie and Warren Ellis if you like
comics Warren was in it and and Neil
Asher and we came up with a bunch of
blue-sky ideas with Jim and then later
we brought screenwriters in and did
these ideas and you know I just want to
take this moment that you get a lot of
[ __ ] online I see people go oh well
there's you know all these writers
created by and blah blah blah
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot of people
who work on movies but it doesn't mean
because you might have a couple of
writers well
those many of those writers in that list
were there because of other things for
later things and and when people use
that as an excuse to bag on the movie
I'll just say that you know every movie
has to have a singular vision and it
really doesn't matter if it's got two
writers or one writer of four writers if
somebody is driving ship and in this
case it was Jim me anyway I hate when
people like Bagon it must suck because
it's got six writers what do you know so
I think for fans one of the things one
of my beefs and man I wasn't gonna open
the store but one of my beefs with the
the recent Star Wars trilogy is they
made seven eight-nine without knowing
where eight and nine were going when
they were making seven so I guess for
you did you guys do you know in the back
of your brain like where the next two
will or like you know what I mean like
is there that so you have an idea of
where the next two would go we talked
about a lot of different things
no standalone rev 9 picture yes yes on
that out there it's really just going to
be a bunch of beautiful shots that our
cinematographer go out and do they feel
reminiscent of terminator no it's gonna
be just gaben our two movies a billion
euros during behind the camera kin stop
whispering I'm trying to find something
here never mind
yeah we had we have yes there is there
is an arc but once we started making
this movie it becomes it has a life of
its own it becomes its own thing and
then maybe they'll stick to the broad
ideas that we had before maybe they
won't I don't know
believe me I have questions for the two
of you but I'm gonna drill down a little
bit more when in the writers room did
you guys know Linda and Arnold are
definitely coming back or are you
developing with the idea that it may or
may not include Linda in Arnold
well you can't keep Arnold out of a
Terminator movie so we we all knew he
was coming back like even if we didn't
but if but of course we did and then for
Linda Conti showed up one day and then
for Linda we talked about a bunch of
different blue sky ideas but very it was
a very brief period before we all said
like wouldn't it be great if Linda came
back and Jim said mmm I'll ask her and
then and then we sat around like on pins
and needles for a couple days
while Jim connected with Linda because
you know the first three times he called
her she didn't call him back and then
finally she said I'll think about it and
if anybody thinks that Jim Cameron or me
or anybody else talked Linda Hamilton
into doing this movie you don't know
Linda Hamilton nobody talked to Linda in
deterrence yet she decided that this was
a good time because enough time had
passed that it really it created a
really rich backstory for her character
to draw upon and a whole new arc so she
wasn't playing just the same character
again she had a lot of nuance to add to
it well when we when I had my skype call
with Jim I didn't meet Jim until we had
a Skype call like three weeks ago
and he said that he just wrote a list of
all knowing Linda Hamilton he just wrote
a list of all the reasons she shouldn't
do it and handed it over to him knowing
that she would just do the opposite but
uh she when I found out she was in this
movie like whenever was three years ago
whenever I read that Linda Hamilton is
in the picture I was gonna be right
where you are my butt was in the seat
ticket was bought and sold I mean I was
ready to go so I was happy she was in
the movie and even happier that I was
[ __ ] there for some reason I'm curious
when did you know when did it all come
together that this is gonna be a sequel
to t2 look when did that finally get
figured out well I think when Linda's
definitely said she would come back I
mean I feel like regardless with Jim
involved it would be a sequel we would
pick up with that whether they had to
say well Sarah Connor died or whatever
it would be a continuation in that story
because it was a gym store he would he
was the writer he he was the originator
of the whole idea so we knew it was
going to be a continuation of that but
as soon as Linda said yeah I'll do it
then it just really locked us into a
specific direction for all of it and I
kind of feel like you this is the story
that sort of needed to be told even some
things that maybe some of the fans
disagree with some choices we made you
got to look at it all as fuel for that
characters arc nobody wants to see a
[ __ ] happy content Linda Hamilton or
Sarah Connor nobody wants to see a Sarah
Connor that's not tormented by demons of
the choices she made and so you have to
create some tragedy that really compels
her to be her true self and anyway those
those decisions that people go oh that's
terrible you when you stop and think
about it I think it makes a little more
sense I'm curious about the way you guys
work in pre-production and coming up
with the look of the film how you the
colors just all the stuff that happens
can you sort of share how you guys work
together in pre-production to get the
film ready
kid I just want to say before Ken so I
can unleash him to tell you the truth
here that this is only my second movie
and I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
and I did I didn't know much about
live-action going into Deadpool and I
know only slightly more after terminator
and the way the movie looks and the way
it really creates this wonderful
cinematic experience is all this guy
right here because I could not do it
without him and on set I mean it's to an
embarrassing degree like the actors ago
so what's the next shot Tim and I'll go
Ken again what do we what are we doing
next so so you can now that it's the
cats out of the bag you can tell them
the truth ken well he's lying a little
bit because before I get on the movie he
does an incredible amount of work kind
of storyboarding and Moe capping the big
action sequences so there's usually a
pretty good game plan for us to go in
and look at all those action sequences
and then I'll look at a rough draft of
those with the layout people who
generally are putting those things
together and then we'll sort of make
adjustments to that and then a lot of
the time on the things that are more
dramatic Tim and I will kind of figure
those things out when we're in
pre-production and sort of go to
location scouts sit there come up with
ideas and then you know we kind of go at
it so it's a very collaborative working
relationship so he's lying a little bit
when he says he doesn't do anything
not really what cameras did you use on
this and why well that that could be a
very long story but I'm going to keep it
brief we shot on the large-format Alexa
which had just come out and one of the
important things for us gosh this story
could be deep we were originally wanted
to shoot 6.5 K spherical on the Alexus
65 budget constraints even on a 220
whatever a million dollar movie is is
two hundred thousand on a hundred and
ten thousand dollar movie we had a half
a million dollar or overage and we ended
up having to go from six K to 4 K and so
with only a few weeks to go we sort of
made that decision and I was kind of
blown away Tim and I both that even on a
movie of this size you definitely have
to make adjustments for budget but we
shot on this brand new Alexa camera
which I really am a huge fan of actually
I bought the a camera when we're done
now it fell off the truck did you guys
what lenses did you use because I've
heard I've heard from some DPS and
filmmakers where they'll go with like
these vintage lenses or though for
people that don't realize lenses are
really important for the look of the
movie
so what lenses did you use and Ken Ken
tries that [ __ ] with me all the time
lenses that were ground by Basques
sheepherders and mountains there was one
of a kind you know it breaks I'll never
replace it but it gives you this perfect
fall off of this and I say no actually
the scene when Diego dies in the car I
did have a set of vintage anamorphic
lenses and not seen I used them but just
wasn't working for the rest of the film
because you get so much fall off on the
edges so I thought when you get it on
this big screen to have all that
fall-off was sort of inappropriate and
people really need to see what was
happening so all of the flash-forward
stuff was shot on Alexa are on airy DNA
lenses which are these sort of new large
format lenses and then all of the
dramatic work that takes place in the
present was all Shawna on master
anamorphic s-- and we wanted to
differentiate those two worlds and have
an anamorphic feeling for the sort of
present day stuff
and then have this surreal large-format
spherical feeling for all the future
work so that it had so much more clarity
to it but we used lenses that had a
softness and fall-off because all of
that was subjective from Grace's point
of view so that was sort of the
reasoning behind those lenses my before
I move on to the next gentleman how much
onset are you guys changing because
obviously when you're doing action
everything has to be previz and figured
out and because of budget and time but
how much do things change on the set
with you guys in terms of you know
camera placement or realizing
something's just not working or whatever
generally the a camera will reflect the
storyboards or the previz and for those
big action sequences we'll try to have
one camera that's always doing that
whatever that beat is whether it's Gabe
driving the truck and we're doing this
pushing on him a Z shifting gears and
chasing after them but there's always an
opportunity to get a few more cameras
onto scenes like that and that's where I
feel like there's a little bit more
freedom and discussion on the day where
we sort of talk about where those other
opportunities are to get other cameras
in I mean if you're going to stage a
massive event like this you need to sort
of cover that off and so that's you know
that's definitely the fun of on the day
and they improvise the funny thing is is
it on Deadpool Ken has to have perfect
lighting and it's hard to have perfect
lighting with multiple cameras so he
would often not shoot he'd shoot one or
two cameras and and at the end of
Deadpool I said Ken I wish I had some
more coverage on on some of these
moments and he said okay Tim I hear you
so on Terminator we shot a lot of
[ __ ] cameras and so there was usually
three or four cameras on every shot
sometimes much more and so much so that
I'm embarrassed to admit this but it's
true I don't think I even looked at all
the footage that we shot for the movie
because there's just - between this and
weeks of second-unit footage which often
they were shooting with three or four
cameras -
you just literally you don't have time
unless unless I just you know like
played it on my ceiling while I slept
there's aI don't know there's probably
hundreds of hours of film editorial
would it be interesting to know just how
much we shot and and I and I am haunted
by this fear that I missed something
great and like the perfect thing that I
just I just missed it because I didn't
look at the dailies well enough on that
day it's tragic and at the end he ended
up telling me okay Ken I think we shot
too many cameras on terminator and I
think we can go back to maybe three on
the next movie yeah three Dropbox me
that [ __ ] I'm doing my own cut we could
we could do so many cuts of this movie
I'm telling you the the assembly cut was
two hours and 50 minutes this cut is too
[ __ ] I don't even know it changed so
many [ __ ] time 2:08 with the credits
right I think that's pretty tight the
credits are 25 minutes long yeah yeah I
know that's true did it feel too long or
did it feel just kind of just kind of
right I want to do a follow-up on that
but I'm curious what is it like for you
you've been a number of things but this
is a really big project what is it like
for you the night before you're going in
for like a camera test and you know that
you're really close to possibly getting
this role you know Tim's really timid
kind of had like this direct line to me
so we were communicating throughout the
whole process and I kept getting a sense
that you know I think I might be his guy
you know I think I might be the dude I
made everyone feel like that yeah well
my slit actually it was true so then
can't change that let's relate yeah so
he you know he eventually they were like
first I was going to do a screen test
and I wasn't but then he's like finally
like Gabe
income to blur we're gonna do a screen
size and I was like alright you know it
been four and a half months up into that
point so it was just another flaming
hoop to go through and I was happy to do
it because I show up to the test and he
comes to me and he's like hey you're my
guy dude and and I told Jim this and I
just sent me your press and all your
tape and everything else but he still
wants to test you he told me that he
said Tim I once built the whole jungle
for a screen test such as testing which
was true apparently apparently he built
the jungle to Sam for the for the Avatar
movie seems like an awfully unnecessary
expenditure but I don't that's why he's
him and I'm not but yes so so we went to
blur and you know at that point you know
I was in I was in the mode I was already
training as if I had the job I was very
confident that it might work out so you
know I wasn't I wasn't tossing and
turning or anything I just was ready to
go what did they what was your camera
test what you have to do I did the scene
where I walk up to those two Texas
Rangers and kind of shooting a [ __ ] with
them at first and then and then in the
scene or in the screen test I I just
decapitate the dude and I like this arm
um and I put a bullet through one of a
minute you know I've impale the other
guy so there's a lot more action in that
scene but you know you gotta you gotta
sacrifice some things for the sake of
people being able to go home at some
point yeah I mean oddly enough I it just
may not mean anything to you guys but to
me it's super [ __ ] important but on
both Deadpool and Terminator I got a
hundred percent of my casting selects so
everybody I cast was approved through
the studio and I got it which is I think
not as prevalent as maybe you might
think but it's really important to me
because I it's not only that you want
people that are great actors but I try
and spend a little time with Gabe and
Kenzie and these guys because it's such
an intense atmosphere on the set and
everybody is under pressure and you just
don't want to be in that [ __ ] life
but with a bunch of [ __ ] and
you want to know that they're good
people and that they're not gonna you
know give a lot of attitude to the crew
or treat everybody else poorly and you
spend that time so in the case of every
single actor in this movie they are all
the ones I picked but every time I would
go to gym and I would say I think Gabe
is the one he's great I'm happy he's a
man and Jim would go I'd like to see
another test okay and then you know
Natalia I think she's great she's
amazing Linda [ __ ] loves her we I'd
like to see another test okay you know
and it was just that's for whatever
reason he he liked that new test that he
saw but yeah and we all do by that point
we had the script in decent shape so we
could actually test scenes from the
movie unlike you know we tested
Gabe's first test was I I slightly
modified a scene from collateral with
Tom Cruise because you know he goes from
sort of affable guy from out of town to
stone-cold killer and Gabe can do this
with his eyes it's really it's really
it's really sexy I do I remember
actually sitting at Blair studios and
Tim being like come here come here come
here this guy is gonna be the evil
Terminator check it out check it out and
we all were like hovered around this
monitor watching this green test and you
just got chills when you just saw Gabe
just like turn on that stone-cold thing
and what adventures say Tim Tim went to
a Fincher and show them the same things
like what's his superpower freckles and
no-take features saw what whatever it
was idea it's enough I've spoken to a
lot of directors and they say that they
can often when they first see someone
like when they first walk in they know
how long would it does it typically take
for you when someone walks in you're
like that's the person or do you
actually have to see the performance and
the delivery no I I don't believe when
they say that because I mean you know
you can't tell you because there's so
many things I I have kind of a route my
own little routine which is
mmm-hmm I usually let everybody do three
reads even if the first one sucks
because they took the time to learn the
material and make the track come in so I
feel like I owe them that but if if they
do those reads good and I write the
sides in such a way that there's a
couple of shifts right it's not just
straight drama it might be drama to
comedy or there's some sort of
transition so I can see how they can
make those switches because that's often
difficult for actors and then the other
thing that I really care about is then I
try and [ __ ] with them right so I that
that was great
now I want you to really feel I want to
feel like your mom just died when you
read the end of this thing and now what
about if you try it so that you feel
like you're you know you're telling the
joke to your best friend and then he
dies in the middle of it but something
to like throw them off and see how
quickly they adapt because if you if
you're that person who just practiced it
at home in front of the mirror for 30
minutes or 4 hours and hours and that's
all you can do then that is not great
for an onset environment where suddenly
you need to react to something else to
another actor is doing or direction from
me
you need that dude you're describing
acting but you be surprises surprised
how many people come in who can't do it
I want to go back to that first cut
deleted scene thing have lost logic I
see you all right sorry I saw my man's
away boss logic everyone gotta be
artists oh yeah right up there uh I'm
curious it the first cut you said was
like 250 what was the last thing that
you cut out of the movie before you
picture locked and why the biggest thing
was there's in the middle of the movie
where they Mackenzie sees the drone
grace says there's we got it we got to
move after that they moved to another
rock and they came under fire from some
federales and then we have this big
run-and-gun weird
grace is shooting federales that Gabe is
sending to kill them and she's firing
back at them and then there's a whole
running fight Linda takes out one grace
does these really cool acrobatic moves
to kill a few other or to leg shots
because we have a little Terminator call
back there where Danny says I don't want
anybody else dying because it means and
grace is fine leg shots whatever and so
that and then there's a big they'll live
they'll live there's a big we made a
bigger deal of river crossing there was
a helicopter that flew over and great
shoots the light out and then they're
shooting at her all the way up to the
border wall and repeatedly at screenings
the audience would go just and the
action wasn't as cool it feels a little
it felt a little more MacGyver to be
honest and I didn't want to hear it but
but finally I did and we cut that chunk
out how long was the chunk about two and
a half minutes it was good it was it was
the right thing to do is it do you feel
like with deleted scenes from this movie
that you would do a quote-unquote
extended cut for the blu-ray or do you
feel that the deleted scenes if you
release any will just be like deleted
scenes
they'll just be deleted scenes I I there
is no I could I could do a director's
cut of this movie but I feel like only
me and the actors would notice the
difference because there's just what
some word choices and stuff where I was
overruled but but the the general plot
and everything it it's pretty close to
my director's cut originally there's
[ __ ] like you know McKenzie says you
know come with me or he died for nothing
I personally would never put that in if
in my movie because it feels like such a
[ __ ] movie line but it's in the movie
and and you know you it's a it's a it's
a community sport and you have to play
well with others well you know the thing
that a lot of people don't realize
though is when you make a movie that's
like 20
thirty forty million dollars you have a
lot more freedom than when you have a
two hundred million dollar movie you
have to make a lot of people happy a lot
of people have paid for it and you know
it's a big big kind of a thing do you
sort of make the deal with the devil
when you take on a movie do you know
what I mean with that kind of a budget
well I don't I think it depends like if
if the last movie you made was ten
million dollars and now you're making a
forty million dollar movie you're
probably still gonna have somebody up
your ass all the time right it may not
be that much better but I can tell you
that there are a lot of cooks in the
kitchen at this at this budget level
thankfully as Ken will back up I am a
fierce [ __ ] and and I do not I
fight back every every second thank you
what I want yeah I don't I'm surprised
you're not just sleeping right now
because it is unbelievable every van
ride every day lots of emails just it's
very challenging to direct a movie of
this scope and sort of keep all the
balls in the air politically and just to
make the movie it's a challenge kudos to
you I could not do that I agree one of
the things that but I do I do want to
say that I mean nobody's evil in this
process it's just that everybody feels
that they have a seat at the table and
the right to say what they want and and
some of them do and some of them do
because of reasons beyond the fact that
they're filmmakers because they it's
their project or what have you so I
don't I don't I don't want to sound like
I I'm ungrateful or I think that that's
not the way it should be
there's a lot of [ __ ] money you know
and and nobody and look at me nobody
should give me two hundred million
dollars and just go go do [ __ ] and
imagine him without shoes because that's
his usual state yeah it would you give a
guy with no shoes 200 million dollars or
I give him some shoes I I can't believe
that they would give me
let me do this movie one mood I had one
movie before this it's ridiculous I'm
glad anyway that man is movie yeah they
do think I think I think everyone in the
audience is happy you did one of the
things that I really listened a
Terminator movie is always gonna have
action set-pieces the action what I
really dig about this movie is that the
action is easy to follow it makes sense
it's not loaded with like quick cuts
it's it's really well done action so for
the two of you talk a little bit about
crafting the action set pieces for you
designing them and I'm curious what was
it like being a part of them on set
because I don't think you've ever done
anything on this scale and scope and I'm
just curious for for you guys to talk
about crafting these things yeah well we
oh of course a lot to Freddy Freddy Bush
agus our fight coordinator and all of
our stunt DS Jason Morgan my stunt is
Vanessa
Natalia's Julia and Anna Coe all of them
came together and they were working with
Tim very closely building these previz
and they go away they build it they
shoot it it comes back it's even got a
little uh Adobe after-effects explosions
and knives and stuff cutting off you
know and then Tim would see it and he'd
love he's like I love this but trim that
trim that we don't need that punch we
don't need that parry that makes no
sense
no fighting for the sake of fighting
every move has to be a line in the
script it all has to be very specific
and meaningful so so that's kind of how
these fights came to be and I think that
I think we achieved that goal because
because everything and it's very clean
it's very it's very purposeful and
there's no fluff there's no organized
despair as Bruce Lee would put it
there's no unnecessary flourishes so so
that's in terms of the fighting that is
that then you have vehicular stunts Mike
massive canyons and [ __ ] legend Lance
Gilbert the greatest stunt drivers there
is Debbie and Mike Ryan who drove my
drove my Bay Bridge so we certainly had
although he definitely hired all the
right people they built a lot of cool
stuff Gabe step in that before because
we were before then I write all the
actions
so we decide there's gonna be a big C 5
action C and then I'll write that out
and eat before the writers even done
strip so I'll write these very elaborate
Long Beach sheets they really don't have
any dialogue but it just describes you
action this happens and this happens
this happens upload pictures in there so
everybody gets the right idea and then I
hand that to the writer because Billy
Ray who wrote this doesn't really give a
[ __ ] about action so he's dude just give
me the action I'll put it in there and
make make the character moments relevant
inside that so that's kind of what
happens first and that becomes the
template for the stunt team to go and
it's great because I can hand those
documents out pretty early to guys like
Ken there's a lot of fun to do that's
for sure I had these little like foam
stabby hands that I was using as a
template for for island and blood and
all the guys and the effects and and it
was a lot of fun to work all that out
and be taught this new set of skills so
I think one of the things that makes
action scenes watchable and simple to
take in is abiding by these very simple
principles of the why of the 180 degree
rule and we would a lot of times get
stunt vis in and get certain things in
and realized that certain beats were
confusing and if you sort it down to
some of these more simple rules about
prop maintaining proper screen direction
in these complex fights that are taking
place three dimensionally you often have
to rein things in in that way in order
to just have them make sense but people
who are watching them and that was a big
thing because you might have a second
unit shooting two weeks after in a
totally different country and you're
trying to talk to them about some
direction 180 degree rule which way are
the vehicles moving which way are the
people
moving that was actually a lot that went
into all the communication both in sort
of hand-to-hand combat fights but also
in the in the really big sort of action
sentences like the car chase built a
full 360 degree in war for the c5 scene
so the fuselage of the c5 you can
imagine is able to rotate a fool Bree
it's as big as this room it reaches up
to the ceiling of this moment and it was
just going in a full circle like just
one big massive Jamiroquai video and
like everybody's in it and we're all we
all test it for the first time and they
like citizens tripping like we're about
to go in the [ __ ] Tower of Terror or
whatever it is and an Arnold sitting
next to me and we all start going
alright take it to 90 we go we're going
back
he looks amigos this is why Tim is known
for being emotional I'm curious for the
two of you but he cried earlier we're
the cast and crew and he's not a crime I
didn't I love it you know I did I didn't
I got a live Craig's so he's got a tear
duct problem okay so forget about the
curious onset what's a day that you
remember Tim getting very emotional it's
kind of heavy
you know considering subject matter but
I appreciated it as an actor we're
shooting the detention facility and
there you have hundreds of sure that
they're paid actors have paid back on
the fridge but they're still in cages on
cold floors they can go for a break
evoke Rafi but the ones that are
actually there right now can't in fully
acknowledge that and took a moment to
have a moment with the cast and I don't
know what we're doing
how much it meant to him that we commit
that to cinema just make people
encounter have habit and all they should
we didn't think that this is [ __ ]
tragedy used to be going on the movie
came out but sadly it is so yeah he had
some emotions to me he shed a tear that
day so I appreciate you I would I would
say that the whole crew I get emails
from crew in Spain I get emails from
crew in Budapest telling me that this is
still the best film they've ever worked
on from a crews standpoint and I fully
believe that comes culturally from the
top in the way that Tim talks about
hiring actors crew and that sort of
filters down through the whole thing and
I think you're gonna spend eleven months
you know sometimes away from your family
that you better do it with an army of
good people and I think a lot of credit
goes to Tim you see the movie you just
have a sense that the crew and everybody
but I know what do anything pretend
because he's such a good dude and you
know just something you can get behind
that's not the case on most movie sets
no boot gift card I'm sorry I didn't
want to do that but I'm excited about
that
one of the things that I appreciate
about this movie as well is that you had
three female three strong female
protagonists
was that talk a little bit about the why
you wanted to do that and was it at any
point hard to get it through or you know
enemy because it's hard to it's an
unusual thing I mean I think it should
be more movies but it's an unusual thing
no there was no pushback on that you
know and I can honestly say I
there's no I don't I have enormous
respect I mean but I don't have some
agenda because as a guy one thing I have
learned is that I'm not allowed to have
that a general that I can do what I can
but I can't speak I can't say something
about in modern world so to me I really
loved with Mackenzie's
press tour and then these are just
strong characters and it's not I really
like that and they in there and they are
their gender is there for very different
reasons none of which particular drum to
beat but we we didn't want to do the
same thing as head with Natalia we
didn't want to do the same thing as hope
not to but I didn't want to do the same
thing that we had been done in the
previous movies and that was one of
those things where we could really
change it up and we thought this was an
interesting way to do it for Mackenzie's
character she was invented grace was
invented by this author Joe Abercrombie
who came to the writers room and the
minute she came out of Joe's head if it
was with the she what we had come back
she's a super solo futures really [ __ ]
yes take my drugs versus half his
operation to enhance her and it just
never was anything other than that
yes and then of course she's she's the
strong so I mean it couldn't I have a I
have a daughter I love the idea that
she's got someone to look to and
identify and these kinds of movies I'm
very glad that I want nothing more it
has so many implications but but it's
true and so it makes me happen but
nobody fought everyone so you know and I
too came obviously speech boys in space
it's it was always there it's built into
the genetic code of Terminator movies
it's it's a [ __ ] kind of story
and and of course there's women warriors
and I think for me personally it's just
interesting to watch these creators
spirits and what would drive them to
take up and shusui destruction strings
of death so that's an interest that's
just an interesting story to see but
yeah they're all pretty [ __ ] cool I
mean there's but Easter eggs in the
movie is there anything that people
should be looking out for you start with
[Music]
and and I think when you look at the
movie go probably half of the things we
probably say oh that's no monster teach
you or do you want are really done just
from us trying to solve the same kind of
problem yeah so future yeah
people in arches there's little ones
like I wouldn't say they're Easterners
like hidden grace arrival with the time
of pops up the car that almost it's the
time bubbles Sara's car and because in
my little head that back story was Sara
was coming to kill whatever popped out
at that time bubble and if it require
hadn't wrecked she would have shot
racing head which I originally he was
seen where grace figures that out
hey wait said we were there you want to
shoot me in the [ __ ] head
there didn't think for sure but not
sorry not you can look for maybe they're
down which which sequence off tonight
people talk about how that in the
editing room
they'll constantly go back to a sequence
and tweak it or though was there one
sequence you kept on going back to in
the Edit yeah but you know what got a
lot of editing done to it and mostly
it's because there was a longer piece of
Natalia crying in grieving for Diego
that we initially the audience reaction
was that Natalya trying to they didn't
feel like she's the initial reaction to
visit she she didn't seem strong enough
because she was very emotional which I
violently [ __ ] disagreed with what it
shows up in the cars all the time and so
we did this kind of whole passive
modulation there one of them was to cut
out this longer bit of speech which I'll
put it on the extra because she farted
it's mostly talking about but but it's
just really emotional to see mr. talk
brother and how he doesn't carry wallet
nobody's gonna know who he is it's more
than what's in there any she's a great
actor she yeah that was her audition
scene showed us showed us everything
yeah and he was constantly showing us
stuff and he showed us as how his
audition and you say [ __ ] Kirsten pick
like Natalia she had narrowed it down
screen tested the casting for that role
and I picked five really interesting
Natalia was like number three and she
read I started to set up the scene and
in tears she as I'm just setting on
scene she's nothing acting yet my whole
and then and then she does the scene and
she walks out and then he goes bingo
she's the one and I said really and then
he goes do I get a vote do you know and
she said well if I do she's the one and
it turns out and then she had to fly to
Dublin to do a screen test it's so did
all of us as McKenzie was shooting
[Music]
I need some more that's it so so we go
to Dublin you have a few scenes that
take place in the future in the film was
there ever talk about doing more stuff
in the future in this movie is there any
deleted scenes from the 9 shannon long
picture let me what are we still talking
about that's what's happening who's that
hey go that guy sorry I know I'm curious
was her ever more future stuff in the
movie did you ever talk about doing more
interest doesn't know there is a deleted
scene we shot a difference for that the
flash-forward where we see Danny and the
future there's a different the extra
scenes in that scene with the drag
that's called the dragon there that
scene is actually significantly longer
Tom hoppers Kenzi saves him but can't
kill him faster was it all finished in
the editing room and then you cut it no
it got to a post is it was in my
director's cut of a longer version of
that but he's also lol Academy and
Braille Academy great guy great actor
and just inhuman I mean like the guy if
I was gonna
the dude because he's got arms like the
just there me and he's a great actor and
he did a really good job and I just it
seems cool but it all takes me I at the
end of the day you realize as much as
you like some moment or something Kenzi
show will bring it up to the audience I
see a question sure anything for you man
we're gonna get a novitiate as that
female dude it's really awesome what was
it like yeah well I saw the first
Terminator as a 19 year old my mother
was a 15 year old widower Gianna so you
know she's very young there's a lot of
cool [ __ ] she wanted to get into full
stuff she want to see you she you just
took this along and in this instance
that's what was so I've always loved
this story and it's always been one of
my favorites and then eventually I would
watch the original which I you know my
cousins had and there was like this
dusty VHS sleeve and it looked like some
[ __ ] that was cursed that if I watched
it something bad was gonna happen and as
someone who has always been just I just
did my best man you know we want to make
a film that was sit at the table with
the first two and as we further and
further into the process and as we
started getting more and more in the can
I kept looking back stand back and you
look at all the brushstrokes and of
course
team in editorial Isle and all the
Wizards blur everybody they put the
bells and whistles and what you saw is
what you know doing it was cruise you
know your your special friend so yeah
you talk ya know and it was that when we
were doing the round say before we miss
a fair amount we did like a round table
and that was the first time actually
hurting to say those words from these
things but a friend did you say yeah
yeah roll that back yeah can I get that
holy [ __ ] no no working with Arnold was
he just just come off a heart surgery
and there he was with us
two months later working out training
fighting for his show is all self to the
project was made himself available to me
to practice stunts and of course he had
great stunt that was well but he always
kind of wanted to makes you up we did a
lot of training together flex gym
Budapest and yeah one time he just kind
of walked up to me he's like no kidding
look he turned to my trainer with you
community it's just even even he's
always lift you up and he's always
encouraging he wants to rise to his
level so he can work as equals in charge
I make a good fulfilment even then he
was he was that was a red compliments in
my training I was working with who just
as a disciple
the whole gym is a shrine tone paintings
of him and Franco on the wall in full
endoskeletons pumping and playing on a
loop on the screen and that's a lots of
you know so lots of live I serious
especially when it started I weigh 270
pounds soaking wet I was all under 90
just because it's just a lot of
motivation we asked Arnold's team comes
in said ken was a big one because Ken's
worked on a lot big movies and you know
you hear these crazy requests and so
Kenan in our first date he said look
when he gets here because we were a
treatment you went along with is here we
got a mean [ __ ] we got a ready to
shoot and shows up on set no fire and
they got me all scared and but then we
talked on the team his team and they
said you just must have a good time he
just enjoys what set but an easy
atmosphere I just get along which was
pretty much our set Wow focused in
Arnold was just so nice he brought these
guys with him one is like an acting
coach but walk amongst you
yeah and then you stand in these guys
are very Billy Lucas is standing for 30
years and they all hang in on all the
time so even Tonto
even on set and off and there's a lot of
laughs and there's a lot of photographs
that like Ken right sitting over there
with Arnold
it he's super nice guy
so many stories yeah yeah I'm sorry to
interrupt but like if he's in front of
the camera though and we're not going
and of course you're a tease always like
and roll camera
so if he's alone care maybe like and
just wait for you stop you're not
starting and if they're still dragging I
see something is that can I can somebody
move a c-stand overhears you know this
ain't these dogs they do it what are you
waiting for do it now and it just it
just I mean yeah so I hope there was a
line from the predator nobody quotes
Arnold more than are not sure with that
cookie down nice to say no monkey
business I don't know where you go hey
guys so after a couple of missteps they
bring the Terminator back thank you want
to say that I think you should um
additionally when the next installment
its and the returns if you want him to
be a good guy like the t800 or do you
want to stay I keep pitching it that in
my mind the physical human form at the
Red Lion assumes is some great hero in
the human arm and I believe it's the art
of wars like what better way to
demoralize it your opponent and to make
to assume the face of their hero and
make it there in it so I don't know I'll
just write this down there's my guy
write it all down
so again keeps pitching I can I go great
so Kent
how are we gonna shoot this next job you
know what until you stop ignoring me I'm
gonna keep them all right I don't know I
mean the question you should ask about
the timeline is the first two
terminators up until the end everything
happened as it had happened before the
Oracle AERS was complete the humans were
trying to make sure that the same thing
that had happened happened and the
question that we don't answer in armory
is who's who wants the cycle and so
remain unchanged is it the humans or is
it a ninja and that would be whether or
not Gabe comes back would be who's in
charge of this particular cycle this
particular any in time because time is
there is no alternate timeline there's
only one timeline make a change in the
past butterfly wave and rewrites
everything downstream I wish you were
with me today the junket they started
asking me time-travel questions about
trust right over there hey this is a
question for everyone so once this will
be successful it makes a boatload of
money and you guys have a choice of the
next franchise you could work I've done
the Marvel thing I've done the turn
everything it's the horse
it's been out - hey boss remember what
we talked about
Tommy is some really great Star Wars
character for me it would be Neuromancer
because he's been working on I'm Tim
gave me a Kindle with about 50 of his
favorite books and I've been chipping
away at them and you know that is just
that would be all so I'm trying to work
out something - I do love death and
robots with him it would be nice and by
that I don't mean create my own there's
just so many great books like Ken
mentions merriment so there's these
great stories out there I feel like
Hollywood ignores for some reason the
best thing about my 15 minutes of fame
from Deadpool was that people would
actually listen to me when I said hey
this is cool
we should be doing this so I used that
to set up some some books that I really
loved and they could be franchises of
course but that's what I think we have
time for a few more questions
hey thank you guys very much so my
question for you was you know as an
audience member we sit here and watch
this you're seeing something
I'd streets I'm that so so I know I can
just got saved for the first time
tonight
I'm just curious does the artist who
made it you sit here watching is there
anything you see you know it's you know
something you're proud I think it's a
massive
like this there's so many politics and
suddenly it would just flow elements and
trying to balance you know able to react
make something into the important and
balance that that's the sort of massive
logistical it's very hard to you know
take you know just trying to read more
efficient I don't know if that the
interview question but that's it's been
specially product which should be a lot
because you kick - come from King
who's next
oh I'll just say that Tim's talk to you
yeah
I'm proud of the whole experience I mean
it really it's I don't want anybody to
think that we're not the luckiest
[ __ ] people in the world to get to do
this but there's a lot of things that
can throw it off the tracks because you
just said thanks for making good we know
that everybody starts out with the
intention of making a good movie and it
just often doesn't happen so I'm very
proud you know what Frost said the first
time the first time saw movie his praise
was okay he didn't wreck before and and
and and I was like oh thanks but he but
he means that you know in a good way
because it is it is often so easy for
this [ __ ] to go wrong and look there's
stuff there that I watch every time - no
I man I wish I could do like to do it
again I know there's a better movie that
can shot I put up on the screen there I
know there's so many things that could
be better but I'm very proud of with
something and more importantly I'm proud
what I hear from crew that
the best food it was it was one of the
best experiences I ever had and I got to
tell you the best thing in a movie with
three female leads is they brings warmth
to the set that is different from his
male energy all the time and it's so
nice that you hug when Hamilton every
day that it makes the whole experience
kind of worthwhile that's a great answer
in getting emotional no less weird story
god oh no I haven't I have a good
question uh I loved everybody you rod do
you really have it I loved
everyone's individual looks throughout
the milk the movie like his hair all the
stuff did bill Corso on this movie yes
he did did you did you do the looks at
work prior to shooting the movie and
then modify it once they were cast can
you speak to the individualist no we we
did that with I mean Linda had a very
distinct idea she wanted her hair to be
greyish white because of the horror that
she lived through so you start with that
and then and then bill makes it awesome
the same way in Kinsey and the same
thing to tell you we all kind of go
through these these looks but bill is
leading the charge and just for your
edification from Deadpool because I love
this sort of community family feel 10
saying seams and talk for bill Corso
same makeup and the effects John Kelly
same line producer Phil silvera same
fighting stunt coordinator
Oh Sean Haugh worth who was our
production designer couldn't do the main
show but he did all our reshoots wasn't
pretty pretty extensive Oh Julian Julian
Clark our editor who is the editorial
crew is the unsung hero of all this in
an industry that works long hours nobody
[ __ ] worked harder than our editorial
team it was so great as a filmmaker
because Julian was so fast in our whole
editorial crew so on that whatever we
shot the previous day because of the
time difference we would see the cut in
a solid guy of the next day which is
such a comfort because he realized it he
didn't [ __ ] it up
and if you did [ __ ] it out often you're
on the same set and we could go pick up
a shot something else to fix our father
and in their amazing and you spend so
much time with these people and
everybody says it there's you know the
script there's the movie shoot and
there's no making editorial but it's
very true and along the way if you're
open to it
all these people bring so much to the
process you know
people director gets spotlight but it's
completely they will do although I
almost want to end on that question I'll
do one more
where's door head one last question back
here hi
I just want to say that was something
the best aging vaccine it was like
really amazing didn't have on candy
valley or anything like that but i
didn't want to ask it's kind of
mentioned that skynet seven cents a
bunch of t800 to feel john my future
that never happens is that kind of
people open or hospital or a bathroom
features on this
your Freudian slip was funny resuts guy
dancing sorry sorry sorry
well the we called these other Tiananmen
and slow bullets so Skynet sent a bunch
of that Sarah actually Sarah's got a
longer piece of dialogue in the car than
is actually moving she references
killing to over in the longer version of
that seems she mentioned killing some
and then it happened again yeah so I I
think there could be more out there how
old are they depends on you know when
they came because I think it's like the
shotgun effect through time where Skynet
was just shooting terminators back time
hoping that one of them would be
successful so yeah sure I don't know if
but let me just do what he did on this
one which was just show up in Budapest
there he is
you know he said something to the effect
of let's see how this movie does and you
know see he made it seem like Arno could
easily come back or it could also be
that Arnold doesn't come back it all
depends on a lot of stuff but he
definitely says it it there's so many
ways I I thought Arnold
maybe so he should grow the beard but
yeah she's definitely my grandma thinks
he should she's here she grows a beard
there's really answers but I think he
looked great and he felt powerful but
there's no world which he couldn't I
mean even if he got too old to do the
action things you could come you could
say Sarah and drop the building damaged
him so he doesn't and he could keep
doing it for his posse which usually no
signs of stopping no way he already said
Kim yeah
and we said I said Kim comment wait are
we okay do one last one
I love your t-shirt stand up for stunts
[Music]
three
for everybody
out the first question yeah into the
easy one of course it should be I don't
have any control over these things but
the stunt teams bring so much to party
that it cannot be underestimated
I work as closely with them as I do any
any personal production that's beside
phone maybe can and you cannot deny that
it is an art form but to answer your
first question nothing in the credits
are happenstance the hair are heavily
lawyer and agented so that everybody
knows where they're going why Phil's
credit was there versus somewhere else I
have no idea because honestly they they
could have put my credit in give a [ __ ]
because then I figured that like
whoever's going to give me in the next
job knows we're fine on that note I want
to thank so much for doing the QA thanks
frost man and when lat one last thing
for anyone there's a lot of choices out
there if you enjoyed the movie please
talk about it online hashtag it
Terminator dark fate if you're gonna
talk about this screening if you took
any pictures please not this weekend
it's just us in Marty's movie and that
comes out on Netflix in three weeks so
it goes out the Joker's Joker's the
problem jokes right you're still wrong
Joker's cock-blocking us and and we and
we must defeat him and all I can say is
that this movie will make you